hello internet people i'm dave rubin and
it's time for another friday roundtable
extravaganza today i'm joined by former
espn reporter now lady doing some stuff
over at the daily wire allison williams
the host of stu does america on blaze tv
stu burger and politics and culture
commentator lauren chen welcome to the
show guys
thanks for having us
allison i want to start with you first
because i think it'll set up a bunch of
the stuff we're going to do related to
covid and i said on the show i believe
on wednesday that i don't want to just
do covid stories anymore like another
crazy thing happened another expert got
something wrong another mandate happened
i want to do stories of people that are
fighting back which is why i'm so glad
that you're joining us today can you
tell people a little bit about why you
are
formerly an espn employee and now doing
some stuff with the daily wire
yeah in a nutshell uh spent 10 years
with espn and their parent company
disney came out with a vaccine mandate
this summer and i did not comply so i
refuse to get the injection i don't feel
i need it had coveted i have natural
immunity there's a plethora of reasons
why i don't want to receive this
injection so i did not and my request
for an accommodation was denied so i was
forced to separate as they call it from
the company i was fortunate enough uh to
be contacted shortly thereafter by ben
shapiro and the daily wire and they
brought me on to do some special sports
projects with them which i'm super
excited about so it's been a whirlwind
of a few months but i've definitely seen
the direct impact of these mandates and
how they can completely uproot your life
and really force people into some
difficult decisions essentially between
their livelihood and their freedoms
that's no place any american should be
yeah and i just love that you're
standing up and fighting for what you
believe in it's just that's what it's
all about stu you work over at the blaze
that's kind of like the scary daily wire
is glenn not injecting you people with
things every morning
he does inject us every day when we walk
in uh with various substances he's found
around his garage which is a little
disturbing um yeah no it's i i'm so glad
people are up there are out there
actually stepping up and and taking much
more risk than than than many people in
the media are taking uh you know when
you have when you believe something it's
your choice it's you know it is
we're talking about a situation that is
serious and it's been a really crappy
last couple of years but that does not
mean that the government gets to take
over your life and make all of your
decisions for you and we've forgotten
that and if anyone in the world is going
to defend a principle like that it needs
to be the united states everybody else
seems to fall down for anything that
their government says if it's not for
people here stepping up no one's going
to oh you gave me a great segue there
because lauren is in crazy canada and i
say that with all due irony because i'm
in crazy california but lauren you're
you're basically independent you have
people that work for you i'm sure do you
not believe that you have the right to
just force them to inject whatever you
want in their bodies
you know what's funny is that i it would
never even cross my mind for me to
assume that i have any type of authority
not just to mandate that they've they
take a vaccine but even to ask and
that's something that you know i i do i
guess contribute to different networks
here and there i have had people ask me
oh by the way are you vaccinated because
you know such and such studio needs to
know and it will never stop feeling like
such an intrusive personal question
you know i have had to turn down
opportunities because as an unclean
second class citizen i am simply not
allowed and you know into some of these
venues and i cannot imagine being on you
know on the end that's actually doing
that to another person and i think
conservatives are right wingers we tend
to be
kind of like keep our head down go with
the flow we don't want to be rule
breakers by nature i think but things
are coming to a point where it's like if
we don't
i guess resist now then we've pretty
much just lost all of our freedoms yeah
well said so everybody knows and and the
main story of the week is that biden is
basically trying to force companies with
over a hundred people over a hundred
employees uh to make sure that everyone
is vaccinated
the daily wire allison's new home is one
of the first companies suing against it
the biden administration says they're
going to ignore the courts i mean it's
pretty extraordinary i'm pretty sure if
the orange man said that we'd be an
impeachment number seven right now but
we got some more info from the hill here
under an order by the occupational
safety and health administration osha
private businesses and non-profits with
more than a hundred or more employees
must coerce their unvaccinated employees
to get vaccinated undergo weekly testing
or lose their jobs penalties can be
fourteen thousand
per violation and they go up from there
we've got a little more from the daily
wire a u.s federal appears appeals court
issued a stay on saturday temporarily
halting democrat president joe biden's
vaccine mandate that would have required
companies with at least 100 employees to
get vaccinated for the coronavirus or be
tested weekly lauren as somebody that
you care about sports like that's
obviously your first love now you're in
a political fight that's become a very
personal fight does this all just feel
completely insane and what are some of
your uh colleagues or ex-colleagues
saying because i'm guessing that there's
a lot of others like this isn't just you
i'm guessing you mean me right you said
lauren but i'm sorry yeah
i said he loves sports i knew he wasn't
talking
um no this is just complete insanity and
the fact that we're even having this
conversation in the united states of
america like blows my mind imagine if i
would have said two years ago there's
going to come a point where the federal
government is going to require you to
receive an injection that you don't want
and probably don't need in order to
maintain your employment you would have
said no way we have a constitution we
are a free people that would never
happen in this country and yet here we
are i mean it's it's really mind-blowing
when you stop and step back and think
about it now i am optimistic right now i
think it was huge that the court issued
that stay so quickly um i think it says
a lot that daily wire is one of several
countries across across the country that
are fighting this mandate uh states have
joined in as well
but it's just ludicrous i mean and for
osha to say that they have to do this to
prevent quote grave danger
can we define grave danger i mean you
have a 1.6 chance 1.6 chance of dying
from this virus and i'm not trying to
downplay like the lives that have been
lost by it but that those are very very
slim numbers and i would imagine even
lower right for people who are of
working age so this is just completely
unjustified it's a constitutional
violation in every way shape and form
it's such a blatant overreach of the
government i mean i think even this
administration knows that they they
don't have the legal authority to do
what they're doing and i just i just
caution the american people who who
think the vaccination is the way out of
this and the mandates are the way to get
there like what are you willing to risk
to achieve this
because as i said before power given is
seldom return and you go down this road
where do you draw the line
where do you draw the line when the
government can have uh the authority to
tell you that you don't have bodily
autonomy and what you have to do with
your body that that's freaking scary to
me i don't know about you guys and i i
honestly think when i talk to people as
individuals when i connect with them on
an individual level they understand this
is wrong but it's when they get in this
like group think or this corporate
culture they say no no we have to do it
but individually they see that this is
such a violation
all right now to the other lauren i
thought it was my body my choice wasn't
that the feminist thing
yeah well it's funny it's my body my
choice except except when it comes to
this vaccine apparently and the
reasoning i've heard for the difference
is that well you know your vaccination
status actually affects someone else so
it's like i don't think you want to
start bringing who else abortion effects
into the argument you may not like where
that is going but um in any case there's
been like this almost huge 180 when when
it comes to people who traditionally say
they are for workers rights and things
like that and now we see people who
traditionally are you know pro-labor
they are condemning uh workers who go on
strike against these vaccine mandates
they are supporting the idea that if you
lose your job because you're not
vaccinated you should not be able to
claim unemployment benefits they are
siding with big government they are
siding with big uh big pharma it's just
very strange how there's almost this
double speak they still believe that
they are on you know the side of the
little guy meanwhile they they have the
their boots on the necks of so many
different companies and states and it's
great to see actually some pushback in
the united states because like in canada
in australia aside from i'm not saying
every canadian and every australian has
taken this rolling over but by and large
uh yeah the populations do support this
the populations are going along with
this and it's been
honestly a blow to my morale as as a
canadian and as you know someone who has
visited australia and wanted to go back
at some point to see how uh these people
by and large again general generalizing
um are so quick to throw away for their
freedom right so clearly i mean a whole
bunch of people are just you know
staying silent and staying scared but
there are tons of videos also of people
pushing back and you know
there are rallies in paris and even in
australia and some in canada and
elsewhere stu we never see any of that
on the media which maybe is even more
specifically to lauren's point it's like
we all kind of feel like we're losing
because the media doesn't even show us
what's actually happening and there is
some pushback there is some pushback and
i think people do recognize that this
just feels wrong it feels off it doesn't
feel
very american and it's because we've
come a long way you know i think there
you know conservatives have spent a lot
of time talking about whether you know
they might think the vaccines aren't as
effective as have been reported or um
talking about maybe covid isn't as bad
as others you know have said and all
that's really important stuff to cover
but it boils down to this if the vaccine
was 100 percent effective and it and
covet killed every single person who got
it you still shouldn't be able to do
this you still shouldn't be able to
mandate that people take it we are this
is an individualist base of a society we
are not a collectivist society and this
is i think this will eventually be
overturned in the courts i i am hopeful
on that front but first of all you're
going to have a bunch of businesses
doing it anyway in preparation as this
goes for forward and there's a
fundamental seed in our our country
that allows this sort of nonsense to go
on you know you look at osha and the
standard that is set by osha i i wrote
this down so i'd remember it but the
quote that's that creates the idea that
osha can do this is if it is reasonably
necessary or appropriate to provide safe
or healthful employ employment or places
of employment
that is that could be anything
it could be anything and all the only
thing that matters with that standard is
who's in power if if someone who likes
the vaccines in power one day who knows
we could have tomorrow if someone gets
uh becomes president and they think that
the cure to this is mask mandates or
vitamin d
or hydroxychloroquine
or whatever else they can have that same
exact standard and there's so much of
this in our administrative state that
allows people to think they can get away
with this crap and it should be a focus
on any party that actually cares about
personal liberty which the republicans
continually say they do to do something
about this yeah and to your point the
way they use language is so orwellian
because the implication is that if you
don't go along with them that you're the
unreasonable one and it's like you're
not going to believe this but a couple
weeks ago my producer sitting right here
michael had the sniffles he had the
sniffles and he said dave should i come
into work today i said maybe don't come
in today if you feel better you can come
in tomorrow and we all survived everyone
in this room is alive and healthy it's
really crazy i didn't force them to get
well it could end at any time for you
dave it could end at any time you could
fall over in the middle of the show
anything could happen i want to pull up
a tweet because i i triggered a lot of
weirdos this morning a lot of blue check
people can you pull this up this is what
i said on twitter this morning i didn't
mean to to you know get to a fight with
people i said i know a lot of people who
regret getting the vaccine don't know
anyone who regrets not getting it that
was just my personal um feelings on this
that i personally know several people
who have had adverse reactions i know
two women that are having balance issues
i have a good friend who's about my age
who's really like had no energy for
about three months
i know a couple women because we're in
the middle of surrogacy that their
cycles are off like a bunch of stuff and
i have a bunch of friends that are
unvaxxed and nobody regrets it because
they see that it's clearly not working
well anyway i got a million people
saying that i want people to die and all
the rest of it
is it possible that some people might be
regretting some of the decisions and the
way they were forced into this stuff
allison
the ones that are still thinking clearly
yes it's entirely possible but the ones
that have been brainwashed to the point
of being incapable of critically
thinking and connecting the dots in
their own life no i mean they have
double triple down on this vaccine and
the notion that it could cause any sort
of harm to anyone is blasphemy at this
point i mean it's so
it's so mind-boggling because i've been
on that side with you dave like i got
all the tweets when i had to
go public with my decision and people
blast me i mean they wish death upon me
and my child i mean they're sick and
they're demented and i don't see anybody
who's unvaccinated wishing death upon
the vaccinated like no we want this to
work we hope it's the golden ticket
you've been sold it just doesn't look
like it is right now and the data is not
lining up with with these beliefs that
this is like the cure-all and the only
way forward if you want to use it as a
tool in the fight great but this is
apparently a war we're in and there's
multiple
weapons at your disposal if i don't
choose to use a vaccine why is that a
problem and if i acknowledge that for
some people there have been adverse
reactions which are well documented in
the vaccine adverse reaction system i
mean there's over 17 000 deaths there's
only over 2500 miscarriages this is real
we have to stop gaslighting these people
and just because you're so far down in
this rabbit hole and so convinced in
this echo chamber you're living in that
there's nothing wrong with this vaccine
doesn't mean you should be gaslighting
people who are having problems with it
yeah so lauren to that point is that
like what do we do about the people
because i think there's a whole bunch of
people that either regret their decision
as i was saying in the tweet or but
they've gone in so deep at this point
you know they've basically been like oh
no vax vacs vacs and when they find out
the efficacy isn't as good as it was
supposed to be they still save more vacs
more boosters like how do we how do we
help unbrainwash
some of these people is there a way or
do we just have to kind of bid them ado
well i think in a perfect world the way
forward would be to highlight the cases
where people do have adverse reactions
and you know we've seen uh countries in
europe specifically highlight adverse
reactions specifically with people under
30 when it comes to the moderna vaccine
uh you know there's a lot of
speculation going on whether it makes
sense to vaccinate especially young
children who might be at greater risk of
vaccine side effects than they would be
of covit we've had some researchers
suggest that no actually we should stop
giving the vaccine to pregnant women
until we can conduct more studies and
the thing is there is really no medical
treatment that is 100 free of side
effects or that is completely safe for
everybody not even peanuts are safe for
everybody so for the especially
mainstream media to be acting like this
vaccine is this magic cure-all it just
doesn't make sense and i think it's it's
honestly coercive and i would say just
plain immoral to try to shove this down
people's throats without letting them
know that yeah you know you might you
might be fine hopefully you are i don't
wish bad at side effects on every
anybody but you there are some things
you might want to consider you may want
to weigh things and determine whether
the risk is right for you but for saying
things simply like that uh you know
people have been censored off social
media doctors are uh you know getting
kicked out of their practices for having
hesitancy so what we see is that this is
not about science this is about ideology
and you know we we all accept that uh
you know corporations can be corrupt
that the government can be corrupt but
for some reason now there's like this
cult forming around uh doctors and the
established approved medical narrative
and we should be concerned about that
it's very concerning to not be able to
question what people are forcing into
your body right it's sort of hilarious
it's like the most dystopian movie ever
where the pharmaceutical companies are
the ones who can't be questioned it's
very weird the other piece of this is
that the new thing is that oh none of us
will be safe till everyone is safe so i
want to throw to this video this is a
chicago public health commissioner uh
basically saying that until everybody is
vaccinated in schools we probably won't
open or you'll have to mask up or we'll
wrap you in plastic let's see you know
do offer particular vulnerabilities if
there are younger children still who
have not had the opportunity to be
vaccinated that'll be something we'll be
looking at my expectation of schools
would probably be one of the last places
honestly
that we would not have mass in place but
if we can get to a point where schools
are 100 vaccinated that would be the
setting i i would be particularly
interested in and then
all right so to be clear first off it's
a it's a hundred percent impossible that
a hundred percent will be vaccinated
it's just not schools don't even have a
hundred percent literacy rates nowadays
right their their vaccine rates should
be congruent with their literacy rate
that would be hilarious um but not only
that but also i've read this stat 400
000 times uh the morbidity rate for
children 5 to 11 is .002 it's under 500
children in many cases they had all
sorts of other problems and everything
else uh stu what do we do about this
idea though that you know until
everybody is vaccinated now we're still
going to keep kids in masks i mean i've
seen my nieces and nephews in in masks
you know five six-year-olds uh this is
not how children are supposed to grow up
science is uh is really the thing we
should be chasing here there's you don't
get that anywhere on anything including
all the childhood vaccines uh that are
already in place with mandates in
schools you don't have a hundred percent
compliance on those things you never
will you know every once in a while i
try to put myself in the mindset of the
other side right i for me i take care of
my own health i i that's how i see the
world right like it's my responsibility
it's interesting that the other side of
this sees
themselves as unsafe unless everyone
protects them
and that's it look if you look at it
that way it's a scary world to be in
right
um but we have a situation where
they want everyone else to be vaccinated
they want everyone else to wear
cloth masks that do basically nothing
there is a solution here that's pretty
clear to me
which is yeah i got it
no i mean this is serious yeah
there is a solution where we have n95
masks which do actually do something and
have showed some actual difference when
you when you test them uh not only in
labs but in real and real world
situations for various viruses around
the world and it the best part about
that is you are protecting yourself you
don't need everyone around you to wear
an n95 mask you just need to wear one
yourself and you notice the government
never comes out and recommends people
wear effective masks they just want
everyone to wear masks that don't work
which doesn't make any sense you know
this is the united states of america we
have to be able to sit here and say
we are responsible for our own health
and understand that people are going to
have different views if you look at go
down the cold aisle of your cvs you're
going to find all sorts of medications
you're also going to find all sorts of
herbal cures you're going to find all
sorts of stuff some of it you might
think doesn't work some of it the person
next to you will think that that is
going to work we are at a situation
right now right now that eighty percent
of all adults have already taken the
vaccine none are considering it have
already taken it eighty percent
what on earth did they think was going
to happen here you know there there has
to be some level of understanding of who
the american people are they're not
people that are just gonna bend over for
every one of your mandates they are
going to make their own decisions and if
your product is as good as you say it is
let it speak for itself and people will
choose it so last thought on this for
everybody to me it seems at this point
this has nothing to do with covid the
virus and hasn't probably for over a
year that it has something to do with a
much worse mind virus about humans
desire to control other people and how
quickly we all fold we all have ideas
that will stand up to the machine and
fight for what's right and say what we
think but we see how quickly people
don't do that allison do you think
that's like a fair assessment at this
point that there's another problem
that's not really covered like because
we're not really talking about kovid
this whole 20 minutes so far we're
really talking about the other problem
that kovit has unearthed
it's the psychological warfare that's
going on right now i mean to stu's point
this is the conditioning that's been
taking place for the last year and a
half plus this notion that not only do
not have to take responsibility for
yourself and for your own health but
that you get to blame others if you get
sick that that is insanity to me and
this notion that children should be
wearing masks to protect others like at
what cost right because at some point
you have to step back and say what are
the ramifications of this i mean the uh
the american academy of pediatrics
declared a mental health emergency for
children in this country we are
seriously harming our children with with
these protocols that we have put in
place because of coba 19. so there is
clearly some sort of compliance and
control issue that's taking place a
conditioning that's taking place
especially towards our children i mean
we've talked about it time and time
again the data doesn't back any of it up
so what is this really about it's about
compliance it's about control and i
think the more we get into this pandemic
the morbid that becomes very apparent
and how about the irony guys that this
is this is somebody in chicago where
more children have died of gun violence
this year than of coven 19. right you
have a threat to your children there and
it's not the virus it's the violence
let's get the chicago gun death numbers
for i do this almost as a joke at this
point every week because it's so
ridiculous that obviously the deaths are
tragic but you're completely right
nobody cares about that because
unfortunately they don't like the racial
makeup of who's shooting who in this
case so we'll get the numbers on that in
a sec lauren in the meantime take it
away
well i think alice is completely right
this is not about covid this is about
control i mean just look at so many
different uh restrictions and mandates
we've seen that made absolutely no sense
if we actually care about the virus the
fact that you can take off your mask
when you eat in a restaurant but kids
who are stuck in school at their own
desks they need to keep their mass on
the entire day if we actually cared
about transmission we wouldn't be using
vaccine passports because you can still
transmit the virus when you have the
vaccine we would probably be doing what
a lot of places started doing early on
in the pandemic where you just take
someone's temperature because we know
that the transmission rates if you're
asymptomatic are so so low and you
obviously you can't spread covet if you
don't have it this is all about control
i mean that's why you you even see that
online students who have no in-person
classes are still being i guess kicked
out of their universities for not being
vaccinated which makes absolutely no
sense and
i think what this has revealed is that
there is a shockingly large percent of
the population who is happy to go along
with whatever the government says they
want to play hall monitor tattletail
call the police on their neighbors for
having gatherings when they're not
supposed to and that is kind of like the
main problem that i see right now like
all right what do we do when we live in
a society where you know around half of
the people
don't want you to be able to make your
own choices they want to make those
choices for you what is the best way
forward how can you like live peaceably
together when the other side simply does
not want to let you be
right and dave can we call out the
hypocrisy that's going on in this
country real quick as someone that lives
in the sports world um every weekend i
watch a hundred thousand football fans
pack into michigan stadium or into
tennessee and on sunday you know there's
sixty thousand shoulder to shoulder um
in football stadiums across the country
and then these same people wake up on
monday and they send their school their
kids to school and masks and with
plexiglass behind between like
what are we doing i mean the hypocrisy
right now is just through the roof and
people can't even see it yeah all right
i want to give you some numbers let me
give you some numbers on the chicago
situation real quick and then still
you'll bring us home on coven then i
want to move on uh 10 people were shot
dead in chicago last week 42 wounded by
gunfire
don't talk about that on cnn very
curious all right stu give us a nice
closing statement on cobid
chicago i was there for a baseball
weekend i wanted to go to wrigley i'd
never been before us did a baseball
weekend uh this summer in chicago uh
cubs were very bad uh but other than
that uh you have as as allison pointed
out a stadium filled with people
completely sold out in lori lightfoot
chicago uh you know shoulder to shoulder
but i think even worse than that but you
know there's an outdoor venue we have no
instances right of a super spreader
event and an outdoor venue since the
beginning of covid but however if you've
ever been to wrigley the area
wrigleyville around there is basically
non-stop bars that are built 75 years
ago with no ventilation they're all
indoors it's musty you know everyone is
packed in there i went upstairs to one
of them and they had in action a dueling
piano bar where everyone's doing
sing-alongs indoors and like
this goes back to what we talked about
at the very beginning of this even in a
place like chicago a incredibly liberal
city people are just done with this we
spend a ton of time talking about these
restrictions and we have to fight hard
against them to make them go away but
really what makes them stop is when
people just stop paying attention to
them and go about their business and
that is happening all over the country
yeah well you did bring us home in the
right way because that's what my message
is at this point i'm going to really try
not to focus on just okay the stupid
covet information of the day it's like
go
live your life all right but let's uh
let's switch for the remaining few
minutes obviously the kyle rittenhouse
trial has been this week and it's been
just a perfect example um of the split
in this country that people watch the
exact same thing and just see it in
completely completely different ways but
so there are two videos i want to throw
to here first off half of the internet
half of twitter which maybe i should be
spending less time on uh have
no doubt about that
uh yes half of twitter was going crazy
because the judge his phone rang during
the trial and you're not gonna believe
what his ringtone was take a listen
i i don't think that's
necessarily what i'm supposed to do
but i think the court has to make some
findings as it relates to
the bad faith
on the part of the prosecution
and if the court makes a finding that
the actions that i had talked about
[Music]
were done in bad faith
that i think both
elements
if you didn't quite catch that uh the
judge's ringtone was god bless the usa
which i'm not even gonna bother showing
you the amount of blue check twitter
people who were saying that he's now a
white supremacist this is the call of
magga and trump i mean just absolute
insanity lauren i know you've been
paying a lot of attention to the trial
so any direction you want to go here
well so first off this is not the only
time that the judge has had his phone
ring with that ringtone it happened
several times today uh just the uh the
jury has been dismissed for for the
weekend but there's still a meeting
between the defense prosecutor and the
judge this has happened several times
just today uh this judge is more popular
than me i tell you because his phone is
just ringing off the hook non-stop but
it's very strange for the left to you
know oftentimes it's the right that is
alleging that the left is not patriotic
you don't actually love your country and
we hear the left go like no no no that's
not true just patriotism is not just for
the right and i agree that it should not
be but then here uh we see very clearly
that when confronted with a song that is
obviously patriotic god bless the usa
they are so quick to uh connect that to
white supremacy donald trump mega
political biases like wait a second i
thought you guys were arguing that this
type of thing was for everybody now all
of a sudden because it suits you and
you're trying to paint the judge's bias
you're saying it's this uh you know i
guess dog whistle toward the far right
which is ridiculous he's also been
called a uh a racist because he referred
to like asian delivery that the the jury
had ordered as an asian person um that's
i don't understand how that is racist in
any way shape or form but i think they
know the trial is not going the way that
they want so they are just looking at
anything they can pick apart to say this
was biased uh retrial et cetera et
cetera lauren you're obviously a
self-hating asian because you're not
offended enough
right stu what do you make of the trial
just generally speaking what do you
think is happening here at this point
well first of all i do want judges in
our uh justice system that know how to
put their phone on silent yeah and that
is a real problem uh we do need to solve
that one it seems like the left though
just wants him to have the soviet
national anthem instead and then they
would be fine with it you know i don't
mind my judges liking america i think
it's actually kind of a a good thing um
and we have a justice system that is
supposed to push back against twitter
and you're seeing in the written house
saga that this is what happens when you
turn that justice system over to people
who are on social networks this is a
social network fueled fi uh trial it
should not even be a trial at all we
have video of every moment of this and
anyone who watches it can clearly see
he's in a position of self-defense a
couple really important parts of of what
you see on video where where uh someone
comes up to attack kyle rittenhouse he
brings his gun up and points it at them
they back off and he does not fire that
is crucial to what is in his mind at
this time and we're all going to i think
agree that he should be uh he should not
be convicted of of these really harsh
charges um however that's not really
enough you know it's not enough for him
to just get an acquittal they've ruined
his life for a year
and while i think you can sincerely look
because i have a i have a 10 year old
son
and in seven years i am not going to
advise him to take guns to riot scenes
and try to patrol them i don't think it
was a good decision and you can
criticize that decision but this is a
court of law uh we can all talk on
twitter we can talk on on
on on the internet about what we think
the right choice was uh as far as his
travel plans for that particular uh
evening um but when it comes down to the
law this is supposed to be open and shut
and in this case it should have even
been open there is no there's no reason
with the amount of video that we have of
this case that it should have ever been
able to get to this point and it's it's
scary because we're now
fueling
our legal system with what gets the most
retweets and that's not a way for a
civilization to operate yeah alison is
that the key point because you know even
joe biden called kyle rittenhouse a
white supremacist i mean there's no
evidence that he's a white supremacist
uh and as uh stu points out like maybe
he made a mistake by going or shouldn't
have been there or whatever um but that
we're we're just doing this all on
social media and no matter what happens
msnbc is going to report it one way the
internet's going to report another way
like we're just caught in that
yeah and i i think what's happening here
is what we've seen so often lately and
it's the two courts in which were
prosecuted one is the court of law and
the other one is the court of public
opinion and the court of public opinion
is very quick to rush to judgment and
that's what we're seeing in kyle
rittenhouse's case honestly you guys i
think if you were to pull the majority
of americans who are like kind of on the
surface following this case
i don't think they realize that the
victim doesn't i will call them victims
um the two men that were shot by written
house three if you include the survivor
we're all white i i really don't think
people realize that honestly um if i'm
being completely honest it wasn't until
recently that i did i just assumed i
mean he was at a black lives matter
protest um and the way the left has
reacted to this and and the divide that
we've seen in regards to him and calling
him a white supremacist i just figured
the people that were killed and the one
that was shot were black
and i i still think there's a lot of
people that believe that to this day so
the fact that that the victims were all
white is kind of being glossed over by
the left i think that's really telling
as far as how they want uh to paint the
picture of this trial and what's going
on in the court it's a great point i
mean the guy shot three white people
without getting into the specifics so
it's like he's not doing white supremacy
that great all right we got one more one
more
one more video for you uh which this one
i mean to me when he gets acquitted and
of course i think he should and i i hope
that he does um this might be the moment
of the entire trial because basically
the prosecutor was trying to take away
kyle's uh right to not um discriminate
you know not to incriminate against
himself or his right to remain silent
take a look
you need to account for this
your honor i don't want to
i want a jury here
he's commenting on my client's right to
remain silent
you know your honor i am making the
point that
after hearing everything in the case now
he's
tailoring his story
to what has already been introduced
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation for you to talk
about
the defendants silence
and that is and and in your right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but uh it better stop
understood
this is
i can't think of the case the initial
case on it but it's uh this is not
permitted
you know i sort of wish the judge had
been a little more forceful there he was
a little muddled in the way he said it
but i mean a grave constitutional
violation you may be over the line i
mean it seems like he was completely
over the line lauren you said you've
been hearing some legal people talk
about a mistrial even related to this
right so this is not the first time that
i think the prosecution and i mean
obviously not just me but more
importantly the judge in this case
thinks the prosecution has stepped out
of line so he was the prosecution um
kind of insinuating that the fact that
kyle had
yet to comment on the case until his
testimony almost indicated that he was
trying to like craft his narrative until
everyone else had already said something
which like the judge was saying
is not allowed by the constitution you
have a right to remain silent later on
in the case the uh the prosecutor also
implied that a a witness who was i mean
kind of on kyle's side uh the fact that
he had retained a lawyer to deal with
the the legal system indicated he was
biased or maybe untrustworthy which is
also of course ridiculous you have a
right to an attorney and you know second
the prosecutor third sorry the
prosecution also ended up trying to
introduce some evidence into the case
that the judge had not permitted him to
do and there was another little separate
blowout for that so a lot of people are
thinking that the reason why the
prosecution is being so brazen and
ignoring all of these established legal
rules is because they want a mistrial
because they know the case isn't going
their way they would like to have a
do-over but that may not go their way
especially if uh kyle's defense files
for a mistrial with prejudice which they
have mentioned they may do in which case
if that uh you know does go through it's
granted then they won't the state will
not be able to file charges again
against kyle and if unless there's
federal charges brought he will be uh
walking clear of this so that's
something that a lot of people are
waiting to see like i guess what
develops over the weekend and what
monday brings
yeah we shall see i believe stu froze up
he froze we've lost am i frozen oh wait
you're back wait is he back i'm back
he's yes stu you're i was just out
you know what i'm going to give alison
the final word either way because it's
her first time on the show so stu you
want to make any predictions here are
you in the prediction game that's what
political people like to do right
uh kind of yeah um i i think uh there is
uh i do think he will be acquitted on
this as i said i don't think it will be
enough um but
the legal system seems to be one of the
last places we even have a chance to
keep our actual foundational principles
intact you know a lot of people are
talking about the constitution you
mentioned the constitution and obviously
a really vital part of all of this but
your right to defend yourself does not
come from kenosha it does not come from
wisconsin it does not come from the
federal government it does not come from
the constitution your right to defend
yourself is a right that is inherent for
you as a human from god if you don't
believe in god it's either way it's
still yours no government can take it
away and i hope i hope that we are still
at a point where at least the legal
system
can can can look at these things and
understand that even if it's not popular
even if you're worried that you know
some some activist is going to burn your
city down the next day you still make
the choice that that focuses on the
individual case on its merits because
it doesn't feel like that happens in the
media anymore that's gone this court of
public opinion seems to be already lost
but at least the legal system can stand
up and and give this kid his his
rightful freedom after this uh even
after we have this long debate and he
pays a serious price just to get to this
point stu that was a fine closing
argument alison i'm going to give you
the last word you know every day on the
show i try to end it with something a
little bit uplifting especially on
fridays to show people that there are
more of us and that we have a chance and
that better days are ahead and all of
that stuff so can you just bring us home
on now that you've been through the
machine and they called you all sorts of
mean things and you still got a new job
and you're obviously flourishing and
doing great uh can you just give people
a little bit of that message to take
away for the weekend
yes and thank you for that opportunity
because i think that's really important
in these times we've been told a lot of
lies throughout this pandemic and i
think a lot of us are are in our own
time and at our own pace waking up to
them but let me tell you right now the
biggest lie you're being told is that if
you have questions about the this
vaccine or if you have questions about
the motives of the government and the
overreach and the the um
the the
i want to how do i even say this like
the way they're trying to destroy the
freedoms that you hold dear if you think
you are alone in that you are not that
is the biggest lie is that we are the
minority that this group that is so loud
and so antagonistic and so hateful that
they are the majority they are not they
are the loudest but they are not the
greatest and i have been overwhelmed
with messages of support um of gratitude
from people who think like us and feel
like us and look when i was in it it was
a really really lonely and scary place
but i'm telling you once you speak out
you will realize you are one of millions
and you know what every single person
without exception that i know that has
been through the machine either at a
micro level just doing what they thought
was right at their job or at a public
level everyone comes out better on the
other side every single person
all right i want to thank allison and
lauren and stu i'm going to finish up
without you guys for about a minute but
have a good weekend
and we'll do it again for sure and for
uh for you guys watching uh i think
allison's message was right guys not
only are there more of us uh but we are
starting to get louder we are starting
to get braver but what they are what
they are using
is our fear and that's what we got to
take away from them if we just take that
away from them and you just start
telling your neighbors and your family
and your friends and everybody else just
what you think not because you're a
crazy right wing racist maniac just
because you kind of think that you can
manage your health and you know
how you want to live your life and what
you want to do with your family and the
type of people you want to work with and
everything else
i think that's a better message i
actually think that decency and logic
and reason
and love
and belief
i think all these things are a lot
better than what they're selling and if
we can incorporate that into our own
lives i think that's the best thing that
we can possibly possibly do
guys i am heading off to nashville for a
couple days i'll be on candace owens
show on the daily wire on we're taping
it on monday does it air on monday as
well
i think so yeah uh so that should be on
monday and then i'm gonna interview
candace on her set for our show uh so we
won't have shows in studio on monday and
tuesday but i'm back on wednesday and
there's a bunch of other good things
happening you know i have a way of
teasing things to you guys and then some
of you kind of figure it out usually in
the reuben report community you figure
it out a little bit first but good
things are happening trust me so have a
great weekend everybody and i'll see you
in a couple days